para mí para los estudiantes de tercer
grado en este tipo de asignaturas es
exactamente de lo que hablamos cuando
nos referimos al aprendizaje práctico
aprendizaje basado en proyectos es
emocionante ver que los niños entienden
los conceptos cuando lo reviso con tres
o cuatro niños distintos y a cada uno le
pregunto sobre los sensores y son
capaces de explicarme por qué el robot
golpea la madera y cómo es que el motor
se va de reversa estoy impresionada por
el vocabulario y los conceptos que están
manejando se encuentra con estas cosas
que lo van a empujar y que están en el
motor y entonces el motor puede dar
vuelta para otro lado ya veo estos de
aquí son sensores que van a topar con la
pared y van a hacer que retroceda
desde el primer día les enseñamos todo
el contenido empezando con el átomo y
vamos avanzando y es muy emocionante ver
que los alumnos están interesados y
podrían estarlo porque saben que
eventualmente van a construir un robot
pero ellos están interesados en el
contenido y en conocer el proceso y
luego cuando pasamos del contenido a la
aplicación los estudiantes se emocionan
tanto de que pueden usar pistolas de
silicon y aprender a soldar es tan
emocionante ver todo el proceso la parte
más difícil fue soldar y pegar en
caliente
cuando hicimos una prueba en un
laberinto la mesa estaba un poco
resbaladiza así que el robot no podía
hacer bien su trabajo porque se estaba
resbalando a través de la mesa
entonces tuvimos que poner otra capa de
goma justo aquí
para mí lo que he aprendido en este
proyecto es que no necesariamente tienes
que saber lo que no sabes ajá eso es
cierto y creo que poder entrar en el
salón de clases es extremadamente
valioso es tomar todas las suposiciones
que habíamos hecho y decir esto si
funciona y está bien o esto no está bien
ahora tenemos una mejor idea de lo que
está funcionando y cómo podemos escalar
lo potencialmente esto está muy lejos
así que va a avanzar muy despacio y
entonces sí lo pegas más fuerte va a
avanzar mucho más rápido las
resistencias protegen a los leds de
mucha electricidad estas de aquí son las
luces de leds
estos son los interruptores el soporte
de la batería el soporte de la batería y
las baterías
estos son clips para papel
estos son otro tipo de interruptores
estas son resistencias
estos son los motores
esto es lo que soldamos con los cables
y la profundidad de su entendimiento fue
sorprendente para mí y no sé por qué así
debía ser y alguien me dijo hoy que no
debería haber excepciones porque no
estamos enseñando de esta manera todo el
tiempo y a mí me pareció como que
medimos al clavo porque no estamos
enseñando así todo el tiempo porque es
posible y es asombroso lo que puedes
hacer con los niños
pienso que uno de los valores más
importantes en este tipo de proyectos es
la experiencia práctica porque tomas
muchas cosas de lo que ellos están
leyendo en los libros sobre átomos y
sobre el tipo de energía y las fuentes
de energía y ellos aprenden que la luz
del sol es una fuente de energía pero en
realidad usar una celda solar y ser
capaz de aplicarla para transferir
energía y practicarlo ellos mismos para
aprender un led es una experiencia muy
enriquecedora